[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
guys today is a sad day as it's the last
recording ever in the Woodland Studio
here out of mapua but it's also a very
special day as I'm joined by the perfect
guest to finish an error he's the
ultimate lad Who provided his special
talents for teams such as the Hawke's
Bay magpies the hurricanes and he is
currently with the taranaki Bulls and
the Blues he's arguably the best rig for
a front rower in the game and let me
promise you that he has one hell of a
lad he's literally one of the greats
that is Ricky riccatelli welcome Leon
she ever cheers mate what an absolute
honor mate it's great to get you out
into the um Studio I couldn't believe my
luck when I saw that you're staying down
the road my last week at Nelson
um right and you just jumped at it and
jumped in so really appreciate it no
excuse me
um as soon as soon as I saw you message
me about your announcing and let me know
happy to be here mate it's awesome to
see how much this platform's grown and
what you've done with it so I'm stoked
for you Jeff it's only going to get
bigger after this one and it's going to
really Skyrocket but what are you up to
announce and what brings you to Nelson
um my partner's got some training here
um tennis training her coach lives here
so shout out to JD tennis
um and I'm just cruising man so happy
days just a bit of golf I'm trying to
get into the do a bit of training myself
here but um no just a support crew at
the moment nice how long is this uh
relationship been going okay
this is about me or not no it's been
about a year now so yeah Happy Days nice
early doors so plain sailing at the
moment nice and she's a tennis gun like
how how good is she she's good mate
she's a good player I don't want to blow
a trumpet too much yeah no she's just
had a few setbacks so
um she's looking to get back um on the
tour ITF tour oh yeah I'm just going
back from knee surgery so yeah she's
back um just getting through the back
end of her rehab and she's back
competing in a few weeks now so nice off
to Aussie I think she goes and you
travel you travel with it right that's I
always thought that would be like a bit
of a dream eh like marry a person Tina's
plan just travel the world with it put
the feet up there like cheer them on be
at the other end of an athlete
definitely like oh man she trains harder
than them
quite a few of the quite a few of the
boys I'd say in between myself some of
the time so
a bit more stricter anyway so um yeah no
just just Happy Days man yeah just
living life do you guys do a bit of
training together
yeah yep try to do it but eh yeah um
it's quite good because you know those
days where you um your motivation's a
bit low
she's she's always been real motivated
so yeah she's a hard worker so it's
pretty happy days you've obviously got
her on the bench press and squat that is
there anything she's got you at oh but
honestly she'd probably ever get the
squad age
defies
so it's going all right mate that sounds
good stuff but you're obviously off the
back of a probably pretty disappointing
tatanaki campaign this year
um how was it for you
yeah like
um taranaki's home for me now and so
it's been home for since I moved from
South Africa when I was four so it's
pretty real disappointing to not do well
for that Province as a team
um because of where that's hard on its
leave so that was really guttering about
that side of things but it was a weird
one we had a lot of setbacks injuries so
many injuries yeah it's that hard at
miter 10 when you've got um
so like and you obviously lost a few
with all blacks as well like a couple of
key guys for you that really steered the
ship for you last year like yeah theater
and oh yeah pure future
mate huge loss clinic here in prison
um yes I was very tough mate but um just
in terms of results like the drive and
wanting to be better was always never
never a question of the team but
um in terms of getting over the line
it's just really disappointing we're we
were and we put ourselves in position to
win a lot of games but
came out second best and story of our
season really that bounce the ball
didn't really go away and had a little
opportunity there to win a couple and
maybe sneak into a final spot caught a
final but just didn't go away and how
was the coach I mean one thing about the
neck I always loved my time up there as
well always good culture Good Times off
the field yeah it was you know it's like
yeah like it's different Beast day like
it's just everyone's a water lad so yeah
get the whole team on yeah I'm a beauty
you're one of the great try to make your
Skipper's eh
oh well who are you skipping with
um it was actually Kane Barrett at the
time and then he had to retire because
of his head knock so yeah yeah it sort
of took over but yeah that's right yeah
nice good memories you guys won on the
euro
one of the greats picked Euro Stadium oh
I was in the stands
[Laughter]
right and you also also you'd move up to
the blues obviously um Blue's had a
pretty successful year obviously pretty
disappointing way to finish the year but
um how did you find it up there oh I
loved it loved it up at the blues there
just in terms of
um how welcoming everyone was it was a
big move for me it was real tough to
leave um the canes after so many years
it's all I knew um but I guess I was
sort of just at a stage in my career
um
where I just wanted to try something new
um put myself out of my comfort zone
which was one of the major ones where I
want to leave and just for opportunity
man
um got some awesome hookers at
hurricanes and and the blues obviously
but we had cozy and the safu are just
gun gun players man and
um so it was just a good opportunity to
try something new
um
see what I could do in a completely new
environment I had I've been coached by
Leon at NZ 20s so yeah had like a
relationship with him there so I sort of
knew how he coached and loved the way
the style that he coached at
and so I went from there had a few had a
few good mates up there Stevie
um Jacob was there and like Aki and all
them and so
um of course bobody was there so he's he
was like his um he put some fairly good
steering words for me to get up there
right he promised the world a few golf
trips but um now's heavy days moves
cruisy
um tough decision but one that I'm how
close my heart but it was yeah the right
one for me it was just the right time
and you loved it up there he always
wondered how much of an influence booty
had on that move but pretty significant
yeah well like never to the point where
he's like like real pressure yeah it was
more just you know selling the dreams
subtle subtle things every now and then
once a week just like hey mate how you
getting on but
um yeah so now I was I was really really
good time there like I really enjoyed it
um the boys up there worked hard and had
a good goal good mindset and
um the talent of that room up there is
just crazy yeah there's some some
genuine freaks
um so and it was just we built it that
culture where
we had the talent and the boys had
worked hard for each other like you
could see with you know the reeks tackle
in the corner to save that try and just
sort of summed out how much you'd want
to do for each other up there in the
Blues um this year so
pretty proud of how we went as a team so
I'm pretty confident we can carry that
on and just keep building from the year
that's been and obviously get over that
final hurdle hopefully not yeah
but you obviously like you mentioned you
obviously saw an opportunity at the
blues to probably get more game time
than you're getting at the canes
probably didn't eventuate as you're
expecting um how hard was that to deal
with was it disappointing or did you
sort of just suck it up and do your best
um
yeah um it was just one of those things
in rugby yeah if you've got if you're in
form um you're informed like I'm still
working hard as I can to be better and
be the best player I can be for the team
so that's just just one of those things
with footy look it's obviously really
disappointing all you want to do is go
out there and play and um for your mates
next year and you know you that's what
that's why we play the game like you
play to play minutes and you play to
compete against your opposition and you
play to do well and showcase what you've
got so
um yeah that was disappointing but um it
was a bigger picture thing at the time
it was more just you know um
you know what I can do for the team to
get us over the line each week and
really get the teams firing so if that's
what it took for me to sacrifice a few
minutes and yeah it sucked but it was
happy to do it you know like it was just
as what it is right you're a lad yeah
yes I loved it it was crazy like Rugby's
such a crazy game like that hey guys
just waiting for opportunities and just
how quickly it can all change when you
get your opportunity or when you don't
like just a couple games it's
just if someone's going if someone's
having made like you've just gotta you
gotta ride it because it's like it's you
know it's everyone goes through playing
well or they might have a few off games
and that's when you check your
opportunity of your opportunity and it
just goes from there but
no I'm just working hard on the soft
season made and
um just really ready to rip in and take
a year ahead
huge you cannot wait to see it but I
know you mentioned before that you were
born in South Africa so I'm pretty Keen
to hear the journey from the start as
always give us a rundown growing up in
South Africa yeah it wasn't too long but
you were you're born I was born in South
Africa and um Durban the bluff so um
that's where that's where I grew up
um until I was four
um Dad met my mother over there dad was
actually like um pretty gun law he's
from America so my mom's a South African
Portuguese and Dad's American Italian
such right what it makes hell of a mix
yeah I don't know how I came out like
this so a bit of um yeah so it was sort
of like
um Mid over there but he was over there
playing baseball and basketball so true
sporting was it oh man
I think he was a lot pretty pretty well
pretty soon he was going to correct look
um baseball over there oh yeah never
really talks about it to me but then he
just wanted to travel he's a bit of a
chillare so he just wanted to travel so
he ended up in South Africa on baseball
didn't even know they played baseball
there but
um he's not playing basketball for the
May right yeah for the national side of
things so and then um
so he met mum over there and then
um they had me obviously and then I
think it was it was just crazy times
over there and it's just getting a bit a
bit worse I think in South Africa and
like I try to go back to where I was
living when he played the sharks
I think it was a couple years ago and I
wasn't allowed to go back there it was
just sort of sort of a bit corrupt and
bit overtaken and stuff so it was pretty
sad but
um who stopped you from going there like
what do you mean oh it was just like it
was it was too dangerous quite dangerous
oh yeah just the security guard yeah I
just the regions were yeah sort of area
that I was living in at the time when I
was a young attacker so
um so fortunately mum was pretty Keen to
get out of there because
um she financially could at the time so
um
there was a sole reason I think we moved
was just a
um for security reasons and I think it
was
um we're getting you know a bit under it
over there I think it was the crime rate
was pretty crime rate was pretty high
and it's pretty unsafe so
we moved over to I think Dad flew over
mum was looking for job opportunities
found one in taranaki of all places eh
and then um
dead flew over I think a month early and
checked out their spot and he loved
surfing so mate so
it's pretty pretty over not overrated
but it's pretty rated now this different
spot now is that yeah there's so many
people from all over there now oh true
yeah property's popping up everywhere oh
yeah made it as a hell of a spot hell of
a spot to live so what was it like going
from the dangerous South Africa the
country of taranaki
um yeah it was
completely different like not that I can
remember much but um from what I've
heard it was like it's just a dream
resulting like it was loved it there
um so did all my schooling there
um went to the great France Douglas
Memorial College that's how what a spot
that was
anyway enough about that and then I'd
end up going to University in Dunedin
one of my good mates Tay Warden um we're
down there the year before me oh yeah I
was like mate I just want to go it's
either Wellington or Dunedin we I was
like what are you studying anyway
because I didn't know what I want to
study at the time it's like just get
down here just get put your name down
for something you just have a slight
interest in and just come down and I
promise you'll love it
so I was 50 50 between Wellington and
Dean at the time ended up in Dunedin
just to geology down there yeah yeah it
was in my last year I was going strong
and then
um before he sort of took over and
Trilogy is a weird one with a lot of
field trips in that so I couldn't just
um someone just say hey to me I'm just
going to have a couple weeks for a
couple weeks off at the canes and just
go for a two-week field trip um but so
it's almost still got a couple papers to
go but hopefully finished that in time
being but
um
so I was just down there and then just
training and met a couple mates down
there and they'll just this guy Alex
Fitzgerald who's who I started training
with quite um he sort of
was a real influential in terms of like
getting him to train hard and then just
one of my mates bro and it was just real
dedicated and stuff so
and that sort of turned things around
with my training and that I just
remember going down to UNI putting on
like 15 Keys
a bit of a rake at um at high school and
then put on 15 20 gigs generally how did
you do it what was the secret because
that question came in a lot how did you
get your rig how did you get some oh
mate I just I just jammed hard and
um like dedicated like a summer and the
year to just jumping really hard how
much is it like what's a hard jump like
how many times probably like I was
jumping most days eh yeah um I was
swimming differently most days and I was
just trying to eat as much as I could
um
it definitely was some of the way it
wasn't the best way being first down at
University I remember us and um unicol
halls there and there were just so much
card so so it was just there was
definitely helped putting away they just
had all that food just easy access so
um yeah I put on a lot of weight just
through Hardware mate like just just
trying to try to get big so I sort of
left all the cricketing doors like
behind because I went down in the
cricket bag and stuff like that and
didn't even open it so yeah so you were
a gun cricketer too like through school
where you were like I enjoyed it yeah
was it
definitely wasn't it wasn't mate um no I
definitely enjoy today I loved it so I
didn't know what to do when I left
school whether I wanted to play cricket
or rugby
um definitely always had a passion to
play rugby but I didn't get picked
through school I'd play Gothic for
knacky science but didn't get picked for
like the hurricane schools and all those
sort of all that sort of jazz overlooked
mate
you're making the cricket teams oh yeah
yeah I was making the correct sides yeah
made um yeah made quite a few crooked
side which I was pretty proud of
um so it's not like
not like big sides or anything but all
the age group stuff and I love today so
better must have been opening bed over
here that was about three or four months
didn't get out early
usually didn't happen that way what was
your go-to shot
what was it I I was pretty I was pretty
like I was always across my body so I
was always you're a Ross Taylor like
it's quite good down the lake side oh
yeah oh yeah but um pretty much to be
fair
got pretty frustrated out there eh so
then why did you end up choosing rugby
like down it just sort of a natural
process eh like I sort of just I don't
know it just happened I just got down
there I really wanted to be in the
academy down there just so I can get got
more get more training in that so I went
down there not in the academy sort of
just oh we'll come watch you play a
couple games
um
and then it was just flowing from there
so I remember I went down there and I
have to put on this weight and stuff and
sort of felt like I was playing some
decent footy and then because I was
bigger I felt like I could do more in
the field so it was it's pretty light
pretty random how it all happened and
then I just remember
um I was at my Southern magpies Rugby
Club in Dunedin great spot I was
actually playing magpies under 20s like
it was pretty unheard of for anyone
down in Dunedin to go from out of school
straight into Prem rugby yeah it was a
pretty natural thing to go through
um it's great age great under 20s grade
which is a really strong concept it was
really strong so I was down there and I
remember
um
I think I've got a call from Tony Brown
or something and he's just like hey mate
we're going to come watch you play on
the weekend and
um
this is what we look for in our front
row is like just ball carrying front
rowers
um
so we're just going to come give you his
see how you go on there
say no more sorry we came but I was just
like I was just parked up at the 4K spot
a lot I've broken I had the most
carriers
like 15 20 carries in the first half
it's a real selfish
but it was like a it was like a
pre-season game I think even as I said I
made like go for it yeah I remember that
preseason game actually it was it was
Jackson him up over the thing was
playing as well yeah and he just he he
must have been coming back from
something uh from injury or something
but he was down he must have signed the
Targo and he's got the ball I was like
oh subjects I've played him against um
his paper party boys with a stick liner
yeah and then he's just got the ball
they were kicked off he just plucked the
seed very from like just jumped over
someone plucked the seed ran the
distance five seconds well
um but yeah that's how it all that's
honestly how it all started sure like
yeah and then got caught into the
academy from there and brownie Loves You
Loved You carries oh he must have seen
something yeah something about the most
probably didn't
Alvin and the knives and then sit up and
it went from there as I said and
um then from there it was more than New
Zealand under 20 stuff and yeah got
caught into the
um hollanders I think it might have been
that next year oh yeah and then it just
has like a injury cover I think oh true
I don't know about that yeah so I was in
there for a bit only for like a couple
weeks and um at that time it was like
half the Hondas was Hawke's Bay all
right so that's how I ended up there so
it's like ash Dixon Richard Buckman yeah
Gareth Evans and all those sort of those
Doogie Edmonds
they're all they're all down there so
they sort of
um they just said oh mate we're you can
come up to Hawke's Bay and then they
wreck I think it was Ash Dixon they
actually rang Craig football and
um he coached Hawke's Bay at the time
and they gave me a contract so I was
like uh yeah so it's tough to tell a
tiger I was going because I sort of had
that connection but sort of just had to
put myself first and did you have a
contract from otako
um now I was sort of LED Liam kultman
and Sam Anderson Heather at the time
yeah which is sort of just ended up um
us through a tough to leave because I
was still doing my degree and stuff but
I was like oh mate um
it's an opportunity that I can't really
turn down yeah
um this is what I've you know sort of
been dreaming and working really hard
towards so ended up there and
um end up in Hawke's Bay and using that
was New Zealand 20 years so
it all happened so
from there was went to New Zealand 20s
there's a prop oh you're a pro I might
have played Prof I remember like it was
crazy times you weren't playing prop in
this game that um brownie was watching
yeah are you still hooker then or were
you mainly bro I think I was a hooker
then yeah yeah I would have been hooker
then
um
and anyway it was I went over there as a
funny enough I went as a hooker to New
Zealand Camp they could cover prop oh
yeah and then I just got to the couple
camps and they were like mate we want
you to play both the winter the Oceana
Oceana tournament in Aussie
against Australian semi and then I've
had a game of lucid and they're like oh
mate we want you to
um play more Lucid for us oh sweet and
then
because that went to the World Cup as a
loose edit that could cover hooker
because we had Liam port at the time oh
yeah at Lenny but I think Lenny got
injured I am so
um you know it was a prop that could
cover hook us so
yeah it was more just so there was I
think it was I was razor at the time
um so get on the field a bit and stuff
so I was just suited the team at the
time so happy days so whose decision was
it to get back to Hooker like was that
your decision
yeah I was always a hooker yeah it was
always a hockey but it's more just oh
a year at the magpies as a hooker as a
prop as well loose hit
I wasn't the bestie ever again
I was a bit of a learning care though
fair enough like when you played hooker
for so long and then checked in at that
level to play yeah he said prop not easy
no it was it was it was all it was fine
because I had Jeff Craig behind me
um big big lad I was just mate just put
21s in every week and push as hard as
you can so definitely have my few um
but a fully embarrassing moments and
scrums but I had good ones too so
um take the girl to the bed there but um
no enjoyed it I obviously had Ash sticks
and a hooker there it talks about the
times yeah made sense for us to
you know and to be hooker and props so
yeah how many dark arts are in there
obviously
um the front rowers all know that but
like when you're going from a hooker to
a prop like what sort of Tricks do the
guys do to you know sort of a rocky
loose head prop
that's just the different it's just a
different beast in the front yeah pretty
low I don't know it's it's tough looking
in like a lot of
people probably like think scrams are
like you know a bit boring but a waste
of time but that's until you're actually
in the mixer and in the front up up
front or even at locks me and let it
push so hard now the back Firebase so
yeah that's where you realize how
tougher can be and how tough it is so
um
yeah like
it's a tough place to be but wouldn't
have it any other wage ever and then to
the canes took me about talked me
through how this came about
um it was a funny one so I was just hit
the into 20s World Cup over in Italy
um
and then as soon as I got back I think I
might have been on the way home agent
just emailed me and
said hey mate you free for a catch up
there's a um
I think Chris bought at time was the
Hurricanes he um Keen to give us give
you a contract
and then so I was like oh happy days
well I often not expect that at all
which is sort of just like a bit of
shock and then
how did it happen and then
was chilling Hawkes Bay they're like
okay we just want to come back and play
miter 10 cup just once that you play a
couple games
and then I remember my first game of
miter 10 cup ever
this kids Northland
um it's a bit of just got this ball like
not too far from The Trial line just
sort of fancy myself a little meat pie
by the way and then go to I was like
real close and then someone's just
landed on my ankle and I've just heard
all sorts going on oh true yeah so I was
just real gutted because then they're
like oh we want to see you play and give
it those ones they said I'll just put on
the back foot I was pretty gutted yeah
um
my roommate time Jeff Craig was had just
had his AC hours it was pretty sad Flair
day yeah
um but um
in any way so
didn't end up getting a full contract
that year but I saw a partner so it was
it was all right and then
um
got caught in this injury replacement in
2015 and then I sort of had a real good
training sort of preseason with them
sort of just trained us out as I could
made and just try to leave notice done
unturned and hope for the best I think
it's sort of just all eventuated and
in the in the playing the next quite a
few games the next year so it was a good
year
so you didn't you didn't debut till
2016. 2015 was just sort of intro yeah
and yeah get a feel for it yeah and then
2016 oh you take over obviously being
behind closer you're always going to get
a few opportunities with his niggly
little calfs that seem to go off every
now and again but you got heaps of game
time that year I even started in the
final didn't yeah yeah I mean it's just
like this is one of those things they
like
um obviously it's never a nice thing for
a player to get injured and stuff but
um yes remember cozy had a couple issues
that year and got a few opportunities
and
I was just young bro and I just
just wanted to go and express myself and
express myself and my teammates out and
then just show that I have what it takes
to be here and go places in this in the
game so um
and sort of when I had that mindset I
just literally
actually went out there and tried to
play the
distilled everything I could to do well
at least so they would make what a year
holiday yeah remember our first game
yeah
that's what they were against geez was
that your debut and we got what pumped
by 50. I wasn't playing that but I
remember watching it thinking Jesus is
this is not a good start
we were so we were so dusty in the game
there we were beaten in all Fest I'd say
like a scrambles in Reverse yeah
um we've just
and all sorts a but um
now we sort of turned it around we just
got some momentum and then boys but the
belief was never that not the arrow yeah
got that momentum and it's a row today
right that was just one of the greats
you're on fire you mentioned expressing
yourself and you certainly did that and
one of those that photo the greatest
photo I reckon taken on the Rugby field
you're Goosey or sidestepper not sure
what it was but talk me through that one
because that is that is one of the great
steps
oh wow that's probably how not to stay
back
like it was it was in the final wasn't
it what was it it wasn't a lions Farms
got this ball on this side like I don't
know what I was up to earlier so I was
just like check me in the pot away like
on the strike for some reason I thought
it was the right people girls like
Goosey stepped down the sideline I
remember I just stepped in and I've just
been actually folded by two
I've never actually seen the clip of it
or the video of it but I've just seen
that photo and oh yeah I'm like what a
what a shot Mark no yeah Michael fit
Michael Fett's um he was one of my real
close mates they're actually sort of
caught at the same time um to the canes
never lived in Wellington and we sort of
just lived lived with him and he said
he's sort of just like
explored the city together and sort of
just got real close and made what a play
he was that year too and um
and then so he was just like I've never
seen anyone step step to get folders
so yeah that's how that went down but
like were you nervous going into that
final and things like that or did you
always feel pretty confident uh
obviously cozy was Captain
um you know everyone is I think he had a
sore Bay like he was trying his best to
play he played the final or did he play
the final he didn't play the song Oh the
Sammy when you started oh true yeah yeah
yeah but he was just playing because he
had a pure like passion yeah because
he's like yeah so
um he probably had no right to play but
he used to play sure
um yeah so but he was obviously only in
the last half a game
um and then
yeah I guess I was nervous Jabba like I
was nervous I remember this the week
before our VA like didn't see me final
like yeah man I was I was still a part
there so I was I was like all right just
staring at the ceiling or everything
that's just like sweet starting you see
where every city
[Laughter]
look
s well this probably escalated pretty
quickly yeah how old were you at the
time
um I think I would have been 20. true
yeah that was young eh yeah like it's
young but like yeah I must have been I
must have no I must have been turning 21
because I remember
um James broadhurst made me skullless
um
for not a Yardie these filled this
biggest basket he could find
on the in the kitchen at the Cane's base
there yeah filled it with like it's
cracked open about seven Sprites it just
poured the burn he's like right mate the
yard had to scale all this massive thing
it's off Sprite bro like full Fizz in
front of everyone
I looked up to when I was like younger
yeah all in the room and I'm stuffed
all right walking out of that road like
yeah like getting it through and I was
like
one of the toughest things to do
probably and then um you know I've got
through there
um what happened and then so that's how
I know my age mate
yeah so it all happened and one of my
biggest memories from that final was
um
just the atmosphere right yeah it was
something else wasn't it yeah like it
was cold and Wellington yeah and then
the famous Jabba drop kicked
Oh I thought that one had been buried I
was I've been waiting for this moment to
be brought up at some point in my life
but I've really tried to park that one
oh a little special way like I just it
was probably one of the freaking things
right
oh my it was hot man I remember checking
my phone after winning like the Super
Rugby final getting all these questions
like Drop gold match fixing or like all
these [ __ ] fixing it
accusations I was like oh mate that was
that was a moment you know one of those
ones you know you don't regret too many
moments in your career verse to give me
one that I do regret oh I was that
heavier
Kelsey was just
constantly into me that the next few
days those Sundays it's Sunday and
Monday but mate it was a good time so it
was no it was good times though and it
was just awesome to see how much had
been to the whole the whole city here
yeah that parade is pretty special and
or
um yeah just all the past hurricanes
leads that have obviously been close to
winning it and that couldn't get it done
so just like from the um even like
broady and stuff was just cool to see
how much it because there's a young
fellow like you're obviously so stoked
and so happy but
um all those guys that have been there
like slaving away trying so hard to win
a championship and just come fell short
so it was good to do it for them too
yeah and took me through the next couple
of years I'd left after this so I made a
few I think you lost the CME a one was
against the Lions that was a yeah tough
one but what's the difference in those
next couple of years or
um
I guess we still had the we had the same
like pretty much Core Group yeah Victor
Vito left there was probably a bit of a
loss um yourself left mate huge loss
huge loss he's a huge loss
um for the offfield for the info
committee
um but no I was that year was
um
well we had a good year we had a real
good year Well we sort of I remember
we're in the airport in Sydney I think
and we didn't know whether it would ever
home see me I mean we're watching a game
in South Africa I think it was a shark
spit the Lions oh yeah then we would go
they would be at home in Wellington oh
true and then it was like everything was
going away like the Sharks were going to
win this game and then like you couldn't
believe well I couldn't believe I was
watching and then the couple blows of
the Riff riff made some real tough calls
in the main so the Lions end up winning
so we ended up flying all the way to
over to South Africa right and we're
like the boys are on fire it was like 20
what 20 something never yeah I've never
been like oh here we go this is the boys
are home here yeah the boys are home
like no I can never say that but the
boys are on fire and then
don't know what lines at half time but
completely different teammate I think we
blew like how many point later that was
decent a yeah was it how much of
affected the altitude have you reckon
because they always come home pretty
hard but yeah it must have an effect
though like I remember just being out
there
um you train so much for those being at
altitude and
um I remember in those altitude Chambers
there at one stage and it was just just
for altitude yeah just for training to
play in South Africa and what are those
like I never jumped in one of those oh
it's just like a they have them in um
one of the
um
at some spot and wanted to know it's
just sort of like you go on there they
put like six swap bikes in there and
then you just weigh yourself before you
go and do the
um one of Davey gray specials
you're like you're about halfway through
you're just like can't even breathe
through just no oxygen in the room is it
yeah pretty much what it's yeah pretty
much mate so um
we'd have those and stuff to train for
it but like you sort of just you get
there and it's a different Beast day
um but it was real tough a real real
disappointed to lose that game egg
because we felt like we're putting
ourselves in a position to win it
obviously and couldn't get it done so
yeah hindsight hindsight is a wonderful
thing is it and it is around this time
that you switch to taranaki yeah yeah it
was yeah it was it was I did two years
at Hawke's Bay yeah and ended up back
home and was that purely just to get
home or was that quite a tough decision
you obviously yeah playing a fair bit of
footy for Hawke's Bay but I think you're
coming off a pretty tough year out did
you guys not win a game or it came last
or something yeah it was a rough one it
was a rough year it was a rough year we
would have won maybe I can't remember if
we won one game won a cup to one or two
games oh yeah
um yeah but it was it was purely to come
home and
um
just wanted to be a be home play for
Nikki and because Hawke's Bay was well
they'd ducked me in really well loved
that spot I um it was really hard to
leave again but I just wanted to go home
and play for my Province my hometown and
there was a sole driver of it and the
timing was right so
um yeah
and when you got home what was that what
was it like they welcomed yeah
like a king oh it was it was awesome
like I was just
like real refreshing to be in that
environment
um Angus Tarver at the time was oh he's
lad he's a little ad
he was so good for the environment yeah
so now's happy days we had a good year I
think we lost a semi but
um it was just cool to be home playing
for your Province
um some of you grew up you know spend
most of your life and just easier you
know get mum's cooking at home
[Laughter]
um
yeah no I really enjoyed them and did
you get Play Over the year that year was
that the following year you've got it a
few times I think they call it the Ricky
riccatelli cat back then yeah I can't
actually remember Jeff I'm thinking what
it's real four times
I Know Tab house got his hands on that
um Team then oh he's one man yeah so
have you man I've seen your name
not the Nikki I don't think I ever
wanted
[Laughter]
to win those days it's gonna be so loud
he is now that is for sure
he has a good lead he's such a good lead
and then we've sort of spoken about your
move to the blues
um
bodhi's influence chasing the chasing a
bit more game time
um what else we got
oh but in that time in that I don't know
when this was but your all black caller
so you get called into the All Blacks
was this after your
2017 yeah at the canes we had another
pretty good year yeah 17 Euro um
yeah that was
yeah that was my first call I paid it
was
it's pretty special way to to be fair
like it was
so what you were you 21 then I would
have been 22 then sure still young how's
that seven eight I would have been 22.
yeah yeah 22 I think I'm assuming maybe
23 I don't know and then anyway
um
so yeah just I remember
got the call at home and it was just
real a suspicious timer it was just like
um
sort of didn't know if I was being prank
called
in fact yeah so like at the time I was
like oh here you go mate and then I was
like this would be one of the great info
um but no it was like I sort of got the
wind that after like you know a few
moments out on the call that it wasn't a
fake call yeah I was just like
pretty like
pretty relieved slash just really
grateful and
um I remember telling mum that I was I
was actually at home at mum's house in
the neck at the time and I was like
she's oh it was that I saw
so all blacks manager
um
yeah I'm gonna go into Camp next week
and pretty luck
I got a bit emotional welcome it was
pretty emotional at the time because
it sort of just flashes back with the
air like all the you know the work
you've put in the stuff that like a lot
of people wouldn't see and sort of just
like hits you and sort of realize how
special it is
um
and I got emotional because like she was
like pretty excited and you know like
she teared up a bit and I was like
minutes
it means a lot eh so like that's how
that happened and
sort of went from there Jabba
um got called in it was pretty
intimidating at the time it was pretty I
remember as soon as I got caught in like
TJ and Arty and all those boys were just
it just missed me straight away and
Spilled up mates it's so stoked for you
like
just come in here and be you and
um and that's it I was grateful for
those words right and you went in and
what was it what was it like like
um is that intimidating as you expected
um
yeah to an extent I would like it is is
what you make of it so it's obviously
intimidating because
first of all you're like you're the
young dude in the team and
um you've got all these dudes here like
you've they're at this stage man I'm
still like
I'm still looking at the place
man I'm
watched you at school
like just grateful and um
but yeah it was like I found it pretty
intimidating to be fair like and just I
wanted to do everything right
um if I had my time again like then I
would like back then I probably would
have just been a bit more calm relaxed
and just taking it in and just took the
good with the bad light and then
just backed myself and in terms of like
in that environment so
but um no I was I was I'd love today
loved it loved it loved my time with abs
in terms of never got to get on the
field but um
um every time I was in there was
um you know everyone was welcoming and
it's like everything's there for you to
perform well so no what was the feedback
that you got around like staying in
there or getting an opportunity to
get out there on the field
um I remember the first time I was named
I was in the squad
um
it was like I was in the next next kill
with the rank so like in terms of
someone went down so I was sort of
endure a couple Andrew cover and then
um
I just knew like I was
I was was close to playing but like
never like expected to play because you
know like I was just there to train hard
and hopefully I forget to crack I can
play for my country which was always my
goal and still is my goal to play for my
country New Zealand and
um
and then
but after that first
after my first stint with them sort of
um
didn't hear too much after I left and
then the next year got called back in
and I remember the New Year in 2018 I
remember there was I think it was
um Cody got sick okay all right yeah
we're in Dunedin Cody got sick and if he
didn't play Then old have been playing
oh sure and I was just like oh [ __ ] and
then at the same time
um colty got sick so like they were both
sick and then
I was a well so I was walking down the
hall like in the team room and Sam Sam
whitelock just comes up to me he's like
mate if you are you ready to go like if
you have to play a for
eign
[Laughter]
that hard to be here like
I'm ready to go yeah like I've been I'll
do everything I can to for this team so
I've never actually got to get a crack
though which is yeah yeah a bit
disappointing but um still alive Gemma
that's it well you're still playing
we've already spoke about it how quickly
it all can change like get a few
opportunities get in some form and man
it can change quick but obviously they
just named that all black 15
um you would have been pretty
disappointed not to be involved in that
um what do you make of that side and
what are your thoughts on the team I
guess yeah
um
yeah like it was interesting lineup
wasn't it um but no it was
like I'm stoked for those boys though
like it's a good opportunity for a lot
of them to go well
um
certainly some of those boys can deserve
their spots and they've been playing
well for a long time so
um no it's a good good career it's a
good idea like that um ab's 15. like
um you know get those next cabs like
some good game time opportunity at a
different level so
um it's awesome tour and an idea so
Kepler Auckland hookers probably pretty
disappointed as well as yourself yeah I
know I know there's some
yeah there's some interesting stuff
going on isn't there so
um
but like yeah this is one of those
things jab like you can't control as a
player
um or you or you can control as a player
is how you play so
um like if you focus on the external I
just find whenever I focus on the
external in the past like
that's when you know you can get a bit
toxic in your own in your own head and
like you can't you don't play your best
footy so for me personally it's just
every time I play bro I just want to you
know display what I can display and just
play
um you know play for my mates and play
for my team and then you know the rest
will take care of itself just play well
and not really worry about too much else
that goes on it's obviously better
better disappointment when like you
don't make sides
um
but I just find if you dwell on that too
much then like you start taking away
from your own game like you start not
looking at things how you can get better
or I don't know like you can sort of
look at all the bad things and then
forget about the goods so just really
just focus just focusing on what you can
focus on I reckon's biggest thing there
yeah and you've got you've obviously got
the ability to play for a fair few other
countries is that ever coming to your
mind like you mentioned that you're
still the dream's still alive to be an
all black but when does it get to a
point where you start thinking should I
could probably go to the world cup with
another country yeah yeah it definitely
has a like well to an extent like I've
definitely thought about it
um like I can get a South African
passport imagine you and Malcolm Marx
together what a combo oh man
um so like it's definitely come into my
mind
um but like it's sort of
I don't have the biggest like I have a
desire to play for a country man like I
want to be at a World Cup that's why you
play play the sport so
um if I can't do it here then
um I don't see why I shouldn't explore
our Avenues but
um like I've actually can get an
American passport too sure so yeah
um
yeah so that yeah I'm who else can you
play for because oh you're a bit of a
mix you can't play for Italy my great
Grandad's Italian oh yeah so not my
granddad so I'm not too sure how that
would work
um
but America and South Africa too that I
can play for sure so and have you had
any comms from either of those sites or
no not really to be fair not really to
be fair
um
no I haven't I haven't had much cons so
if Africa came knocking yeah saying I
want to take you to the World Cup would
you go
I'm in the hot seat aren't I
um well I would definitely consider it
yeah like I'd like I'll be silly not to
wouldn't I yeah you're gone but
um no I like them as I said like I'm
like in a way like I just still feel
like I can offer a lot to like this you
know like I still feel like I have
unfinished stuff going on in New Zealand
so I'm pretty Keen just to get on the
footy and just play well and just
um yeah exactly there nice and big ear
with the blues are here to sort of get
you back in that that sort of frame I
guess because I mean when you're not
starting for the blues
um you know it's going to be pretty hard
to be making the All Blacks but I guess
that's your next challenge eh yeah but
this as I said mate look it's it's good
players everywhere like cooties and
awesome year so yeah
um
so like it's and it's got the young
Solani there too so they're two good
players so you're just gonna have to
play well and just focus on what you can
control and
hope for the best yeah how long are you
with the blues like what are your plans
have you looked much further ahead than
yeah yeah so sort of just got
um next year oh next year lined up at
the moment and sort of just talking to
my agent a bit at the moment so just
sort of
putting
um you know just line lining things up
and seeing how they're going to work so
nothing really sitting stone at the
moment sort of just having a few ideas
thoughts on
what I want to do with my footy and
um yeah it's still up in the air but
I'm probably going to be sticking around
you got your Warrior's head on I thought
that might have been a way you know
planting a wee seed here
the announcement video
would you go to the Warriors oh yeah if
I could play league I would but have you
ever played it no no I've never played
League 15 carries and a half right
that's the sort of steps that the
Warriors want from their front rows oh
mate um no I'd love to play driver
league but um don't know if I'd be any
good at it but
um no I'm just a big big fan of Lady
rugby league yeah especially the
Warriors yeah yeah right imagine you and
Jordy going to the Warriors together
that would be something else wait who
knows what jordy's going to do it I
reckon he's going to try and play golf
for a little bit
it's really planned pro-ams right he
would go right hey oh mate he's
something else on the course at the
moment he's a freak and how do you go on
the course you're pretty good too aren't
you yeah oh no I'm a pecker mate I'm a
hacker no I'll go right to be fair like
it just just bet the biggest golf battle
you can get pretty much what do you play
off playing with a
eight eight I think that is not a golf
bag okay I've heard it I had a long
break my handicap hasn't readjusted but
um putting in the hard yards at the
moment got a bit of a break
um from footy so
try and bring that handicap down a
little bit so yeah where are you going
lucky you've got a few trips lined up
you and you and the barretts are always
off some some exotic country playing
golf
um yeah we've got a wee golf trip lined
up where are you going to go to Sydney
oh yeah I'm going to Sydney
about eight of us going oh they're
saying so I'm now looking forward to it
just good excitement levels just to get
out and just golf is a good game bro
just to get away from you know mentally
switch off from you know your trainings
and good time just choose some fat with
the lead so yeah how good and life after
footy any plans you sort of spoke about
just traveling with the messes and
it's about what uh
um to be fair like I've been trying to
do a bit of planning yeah um like I want
to really finish my
on on the pipeline just getting my
degree done oh yeah um it's going to
take I've only got a couple more papers
but they're going to be like longevity
sort of field trip papers and so it's
like I'll try and take those off to
start off with and then
after that I sort of
not too sure whether I I probably won't
actually use that degree but I sort of
just want to have it there
um I think it's something that's good to
have and then I'm going to start maybe
like I want to own my own I own my own
business and stuff or something sorry
guys not too sure jab not too sure yet
mate not too sure
um
sort of looking into property a bit at
the moment yeah
just trying to do as much investing as I
can at the moment sort of thing but
um
saw something along those lines or
something along happening at the
community
I'm sort of just being able to share my
knowledge or whatever I have to offer
which isn't much better
um so just something along those lines
mates trying to give back to
you know some of the people that have
been there from you know Dave Dot and
stuff so yeah oh mate you're going to
kill it whatever you choose no doubt but
as always we've gone to our Instagram
for some questions and Ricky Ricky tally
has a lot of friends who follow what a
lair that's for sure because we've got
plenty of questions come in
might have been the photo but first
question
this one came in a few times from your
necky Lads where's the red UE Boom
oh well
um well I don't know how much there is
to the yarn to be fair but um no it was
last year naked golden run mate
we're dressing That season or
um so let's address that season like you
guys went what undefeated and uh I think
it was just Joe a like would let Judy go
well yeah like um we had a few tough
years ago like good players and still
couldn't get it done yeah um then you
bring the comp all together in one and
then
don't even make the playoffs
um no we just had a good running yeah
it's just like we had made quite a few
changes
um and we introduced a game plan that
like I I've never really seen to be here
like we were
going to run it from everywhere like we
was you know we're planning strikes off
kickoffs and
um we had some backs who were just like
their whole plan was to get the board of
the best players yeah like you know your
fastest players and good luck to your
pentagusters and yeah
um your stevies and cutting the hollow
and yourself
yeah right
um and then
anyway so like it just worked our day
like we just got the momentum the ball
rolling and sort of never looked back
like just left and down we just passed
the like can you hear that yeah do you
think you would have won the comp if it
was one comp that year
I reckon we would have been very tough
to beat yeah yeah I can we would have
been very tough to be
um man like if you
generally look at some of the school
tries that were scored against any team
what what
um they're pretty good did you play
waikato in the season or no yeah are you
in your beat now yeah sure yeah better
than pre-season too oh T now oh wow but
um
you know we did play them yeah
um they could get the wood over them
that game so
um yeah who knows who knows what would
happen but um I would have been pretty
confident that the boys would have gone
pretty well yeah nice
nice anyway where's the red UE Boom
um well it was sort of like a weird one
because I had this red UE Boom that I
sort of just like you know for the lads
like a few Tunes music comedy music
Committee of Burton and um
sort of like there isn't too much the
story to be fair but like it was sort of
like
saw someone had stolen the whole year
and I was like hold on look
surely we don't have a fee for the team
like we're going that way like surely
our culture's that good at the moment to
get stolen the security
that's what the year it's not gonna get
stolen and then um so I've had it had it
in like the bus driver obviously
um
and it's sort of just like turned into
like a bit of a cult hero of the team so
the boys just put you know Snapchat
groups like they'd zoom in on the like
they're zoom in on the the mount
taranaki and then they'll put like a
little ueber emoji on the top of it and
like some will be like drinking the unit
or something and they'll just have like
a put the UE Boom in the hand or like it
was just like sort of a bit of the
laughing stock of the team so where was
it so like the whole year thought it was
gone like thought of someone's stolen it
then
I was like hold on I might just try one
more thing just rang the bus driver up
and this bus driver just had it the
whole year
the bus driver on his head at the whole
time I was like did you think just tell
what to tell them telling me like your
speakers here so like
um it was just like the Laughing stop
for the year man yeah boys you know took
the gag out of it oh it's good stuff
like that okay next one
how do you have the biggest chest in the
necky
I don't know what it is now because it's
not the biggest chest obviously but it's
right up there that way it's like a big
chest no I don't know just just it's
just from the training hard when I was
younger did you have a big chest when
you were young or no
um I don't know I don't know to be fair
I was I lost a lot of weight in my last
year at school I was just too tired
again called fat oh yeah so we're quite
fat growing going through the grades
where yeah it was big boned oh yeah did
you have big titties uh I can't remember
man like I don't reckon I would have had
lights to standard
standard like you know yeah standard
tits for a list
laughs
like they call like
I don't think they're picks if you're
fit
the picks the muscle they're definitely
picks now like geez
um oh just from training bro yes you
know look just
uh we had a sum with like Reuben O'Neill
way and oh yeah as well he had big picks
too actually yeah and man we trained
hard yeah like we trained Hardy like
this whole summer we dedicated to like
we were doing like gym in the morning
running the baby's speed as well yeah
and then maybe like and then at that
time I'd be like I could go to the gym
again yeah well we were just like it was
weird as like how it happened day and
then sort of one of us had to go like
we're trying too much and like Rubes end
up doing his Achilles and stuff it was
just like
had some tough times and injuries so
yeah
um but um
yeah so I guess that's just how it
happened yes training in the day get the
foundations mate that's uh okay how did
you come back from the news monkey bar
was closed in Dunedin you were a menace
in there
oh that but if you oh right the bars in
Dunedin my first year were special thank
you back monkey bar was something else
it was like this the weirdest setup man
it was like an old I thought it was an
old it might have been an old church oh
yeah so like but it wasn't the church at
the time obviously
because I'm religious So like
um
and it's anyway so you go into this sort
of setup and you walk in this like this
Burgers like Mosh Pit area like slimy
it's a sweaty sit-ups yeah there's like
these right the stairwells I think it's
just steer well and then it's like a big
like Veranda Topsy is looking down at
all these kids like the ground it's
ground level and it takes like a few
stairs down oh yeah and that's sort of
like undulated into the ground oh wow
it's like a real weird setup but like it
was
um no it was some special times down
there there was that bar and there was
um the starters bar that always went
well right you would have been right in
the back oh man it was just first years
right like times of your life but
the house as well away I was well
obviously doing the right thing on the
side yeah no doubt okay this one how did
he get the nickname let's
um being abbreviated
yeah got the nickname let's through I
remember
um at the canes remember body was sort
of rocking like this little like cowlick
oh yeah it's a little Kellogg and I was
like Matt your hair looks like lettuce
and then I was like I started calling
him lettuce yeah and I was like oh let
us oh lettuce and he just like and then
he started calling the Venus I was like
hold on I'll just call you let us man
the reversal and he was such Golden
Balls man like and because he's like he
was like a big dog and the team in there
he's so call me lettuce and everyone
started I was like I'm kidding me
[ __ ] and then Sarah just stuck JB
like I was just being called lettuce and
then
let's yeah for letters
um in the necky they call me salad
because lettuce and the salad but it's
just absolutely
that's one of the greatest reversals
there's a lot of course it happens a lot
yeah
yeah oh that's what um Jared Eberhart
did for me I mean James broadhurst did
for me as well actually with Jabber like
that was that was what I called Herman
then
he did the reversal to me how did that
come up I just thought he looked like um
Jared Eberhart who was a Tasman Marco
Legend and he didn't like the nickname
so reverse reversed it on me and pretty
much the same as that like you guys
still call me jabber so right he got me
as well
okay next one
uh oh this is a tough one who was the
best Bearer
this is this is tough oh you could go in
categories or
um
well what do you mean by categories
lead player golfer you could
um or you could just go all round best
Bearer is
the record Telly
um it's really tough because they're all
good mates I've even
um Blake Barrett at school like I'd
spent I spent a summer with him
um doing log work on Kane Barrett's
Pharmacy oh yeah we're just like he's an
absolute character right so
um I'm not gonna single one out yeah um
but they're always good lads that's it
um all have their differences like Scott
Scott a little bit of surfing with Scott
at school and
um yeah obviously it's been a lot most
of my time or a lot of my time with um
Jordy and Bodie so yeah you're like the
other Barrett brother you literally
you're literally they're just good good
like you know grown-up mates but they're
just school mates and yeah yeah good
love there okay next question uh most
silly night on the Bears or best piss-up
story these a few regular questions that
come in
um there's been a few good um dues mate
um
no stranger to a good dude
like yourself back in the other day
um anyway so probably like I've heard
some genuinely good ones eh um it all
starts this we had a couple good
bonfires at the cane so yeah I remember
those I remember this one bonfire um
anyway we're done now for me to heaven
and due to like Council regions and the
reasons we still had this bomb for in um
the CEO of the Keynes at the time like
comes up he's like what's going on here
yeah so we're all just like on a good
very good level and bonfire just you
know in Wellington and then like
at this stage bro like I don't know how
Finlay Christie's done this but like
he's climbed this tree that was
slot so high it's this Big Pine and he's
at the peak it's true he's so sweet and
he's got he's signed me out took a
couple units up with him and he's just
up there just thinking units in this
country you know to this day don't know
how he's got up there he's an incredible
tree climb right gymnast background or
us he's got a gap he's semi Spider-Man
yeah oh yeah he's freakish okay two more
um
favorite Golf Course
oh that's tough
home Golf Course
kaitucky and
um just outside okura yeah is the best
um that's the closest to me oh yeah it's
my
um but the best golf course I've played
man I can't go classical
played some real nice ones in South
Africa yeah
um a couple good ones in the peninsula
in Melbourne which is really nice sand
base though so that doesn't take the
cake
um
I'm a big fan of Ken lucky
um
it's a good course but man we've played
some you can you're playing golf in
those golf trips in Japan and sorry and
I often took the other option golf
started to really wreck my herps so yeah
yeah you always had that
it's been a long time
um yeah we played some like pearlers
um in South Africa too
um
stuff like that so but um
cannot lock it in nice okay last
question best piece of advice you have
for a Waterland listener this will be
good
hold on Jim so like are we talking like
just life advice or just whatever it
doesn't yeah no rules right
um best bit of advice is just uh
um I think whatever you do just enjoy it
like enjoy what you do because if you're
doing that you're going to be happy and
when you're happy you can do it the best
ability
um
and if you're not enjoying it find ways
that you can and or find something that
you're going to enjoy doing because you
only live once mate so
um it's a good opportunity for you to
live your best life and
enjoy everything you do and
yeah like the world's your oyster oh my
gosh it was so great yeah absolutely
cracked up right oh I wasn't expecting I
wasn't sure what sort of advice you were
going to give but yeah
[Laughter]
what a way to finish what is one of the
great podcasts and yet was going to be
good glad I could squeeze you in
um the last ever
episode in the Woodland studio so mate
really appreciate you giving up your
time here in sunny Tasman to um come in
here and jump on and see your story mate
you're an absolute lab what's up bro
pleasure to be on here she's having me
man right you're a legend